a 3d shape seemingly made of light
floats in midair it's a familiar image
in fictional visions of the future but
that fictional future may be a lot
closer and a lot more real than you
think we hear the electrical ography
group at Brigham Young University have
created display that is very much like
the displays of science fiction but
despite the similarity to the Holograms
of Hollywood films these displays are
different this image is not a hologram
we've demonstrated here that we can see
it from the front we can see it from the
back and in reality we can see it from
almost any angle and that separates it
from technologies like Holograms that
can only be seen from a certain range of
angles scientists call these science
fiction worthy displays volumetric
images a volumetric image is essentially
is an image that is taking up
three-dimensional space and our
approaches that we're actually using a
laser beam to trap a particle and then
we can move that we can basically steer
that beam around to move the particle
and create the image like when you swing
a sparkler around a particle moving fast
enough looks like a solid line and can
be moved to form a shape we can think
about this this image like a 3d printed
object a single point was dragged
sequentially through all of these image
points and as it did it's scattered
light and the accumulated effect of all
that scattering and moving was to create
this 3d image in space it is visible
from all angles as well as taking up a
real 3d space the image is created by
this single particle and a few low-cost
lasers can be incredibly high resolution
up to 1600 dots per inch although
they're very detailed the images created
so far have been quite small and they
remain difficult to capture on video
because of the videos frame rate the
display appears to flicker here but to
the human eye and to still cameras the
image appears whole rather than being
used in epic space battles or to
communicate with alien races these kinds
of three-dimensional visualizations may
instead be used to train medical
professionals for advanced procedures
they could also be used in aviation
providing busy air-traffic controllers
with more accurate and intuitive visual
maps of how planes are moving around
airports to reach that point though
researchers will have to first master
the trapping and moving of multiple
particles simultaneously in order to
scale up the images to sizes larger than
the tip of your thumb until then we'll
just have to settle for experiencing the
future in miniature
[Music]
you